Nice to meet you.
I am a presenter Seo Jae-won. I prepared a presentation on code factorization, specifically, how to remove boilerplate code.
Boilerplate code, or repetitive performance code, make it difficult to identify the primary focus of code.
And it also occupies and distracts programmers.
That is why so many books and famous programmers advise not to use boilerplate code.
Programmers try to avoid boilerplate code in all possible ways, including inheritance and abstraction.
However, even with such constant efforts, we still encounter boilerplate code everyday.
Sometimes encountering a very complicated "boss" boilerplate code that we have no idea how to solve.
Aren't you tired of this endless war?
I prepared for you all,
some code factorization techniques to win in the war against boilerplate code.
After the presentation, you will win in the battle against boilerplate code, with new strategies.
Now, let us straight go for the presentation.
The really long story of code factorization begins from boilerplate code.
What is boilerplate code?
The boilerplate code is code that is used repeatedly.
If any code is used repeatedly, and appears redundant, it is boilerplate code.
Let's take a look at some examples.
Here's a function sum that adds all the numbers of an array, and a function evens that only picks even numbers from the array.
Can you find the overlapping parts in the code of the two functions?
I'll change the code to make it easier to understand.
Now, do you see what they have in common?
Both functions are iterating the array, performing specific actions, and combining the results with the previous results.
Boilerplate code here is
the code that is performing across the array and operation.
Sum is continuously building up each element of the array by iterating.
Evens is only storing results of even elements by iterating.
Here's another example.
There are functions that start different authentication procedures depending on the type of oAuth
and functions that return different strings depending on the type of number.
What is boilerplate code hidden in this code?
It is the code that investigates the number of cases on one value, separately.
This is it.
In terms of signInwithOauth, it performs different authentication procedures
depending on possible cases of the type.
In terms of typeOfNumber, it returns each different string, depending on possible cases of a number,
for example, being 0, positive, or negative.
There is one big problem with boilerplate code though.
It is that boilderplate creates unnecessary cognitive loads.
Let's discuss more specifically about this.
What is code?
The code is the same as the text.
Just like there's an author for a text, there's a programmer writing the code.
Just like there's a reader who reads the text, there are programmers and computers that read the code.
Just like there is a topic in an article that is the main content that the author is trying to deliver,
A code has interests in problems that the programmer is trying to solve.
Just like there is a topic for a text, a code has algorithms and concepts
to solve the problems, thats the approach.
Code describes how to solve a problem.
That's how it can deliver messages.
Bad code is like bad writing.
Bad code is code that doesn't know how to solve its problems.
And boilerplate is the main thing that makes bad code.
By covering a code's main point, by causing cognitive loads.
For example, in the example of boilerplate code that we're going to discuss first,
the interests of each function can be specified as follows:
First, how to combine the elements
Second, how to pick even numbers
Whether it's iterating from the end or from the beginning,
or by iterator or by index,
it's not so important for these functions.
It's not the main factor.
But if you look at our real code, code for how will it iterate the array,
has as much code as code that solves our problem.
As you can see, if you look at the yellow and the green lines,
the boilerplate code continues to transmit unnecessary information to the programmer,
and distracting him by causing cognition loads.
Of course, boilerplate code is not the only thing causing cognitive loads.
There can be enough other factors, such as grammar of a language.
Nevertheless, the reason of me relating boilerplate code to cognitive loads is that
since boilerplate codes distribute unnecessary information throughout code base,
the share in the entire cognitive loads is significant,
and most of the codes that cause cognitive loads is actually generic codes.
It is because they are potentially widely used.
Then, what are possible ways to remove boilerplate codes?
Here are five programming paradigms, each with its own interesting approach.
Firstly, we can remove boilerplate by procedural programming,
in object-oriented programming, through the object,
in generic programming, through generics.
in meta-programming, through macro,
and, in aspect-oriented programming, through aspect,
we can remove boilerplate code.
Let's learn more about object-oriented programming,
that is the most widely used method in modern programming.
The approach of object-oriented programming is basically based on data abstraction.
They abstract programs through a series of data called objects,
and through inheritance technologies such as class and prototype,
reuse objects directly or indirectly,
and increases reuse by allowing an object to be used in many forms., through polymorphism.
This is a very effective method.
But there are blind spots, too.
Clearly, an object-oriented programming approach is very effective in structuring large programs.
Even the object-oriented programming camp
has a very cool program design formula called design patterns.
But we should pay attention to the fact that, now, the root of object-oriented programming is
not in computational abstraction, but in data abstraction.
That's why object-oriented programmings are not so great
in abstracting operations.
What are the remaining pieces of the puzzle that will fill the remaining area of computational abstraction,
that is the limitations of object-oriented programming?
That is today's topic.
And the answer is functional programming.
Functional programming works in a way that contradicts object-oriented programming.
It's a paradigm that's rooted in computational abstraction, not in data abstraction.
It's a paradigm to actively use functions, a concept used to abstract a series of operations.
It's the rest of the puzzle piece that's going to
solve the abstraction of the operation that we're looking for.
From now on, as a new approach to boilerplate code,
Let's learn about functional programming.
The beginning of functional programming is to release the constraints
that were placed on the existing function.
Unlike other program units, such as objects and components,
there is a limitation that the function is not subject to any operations except calling operations.
In programming linguistics or our thoughts,
unlocking this limitation and accepting the function as the object of the calculation
is the beginning of functional programming.
If you remove the previous constraint,
you will have new functions called functions that deal with functions.
In functional programming, it is called higher-order function.
It's a higher-order function because
they are a little bit more advanced in terms of dealing with functions,
unlike traditional functions that only deal with values.
Now let's look at some practical examples of these functions.
First, let's abstract the code that operates calculations by iterating array that we've seen earlier.
This code is boilerplate code of the sum function and evens function that appeared in the previous example.
If you look closely at this code, there are three main variables.
The input array, the calculations to be performed during iteration,
and the default result value to be released when the array is empty.
Actually, the abstraction process is complete as soon as
you make these three elements into parameters, as simple as that.
Since we accepted existence of higher-order function,
which means that we can now receive calculations, that are, functions,
it's now possible to leave the partial calculations that make up the huge computations blank.
With this Loop function, we will try to rewrite the code sum function that was previously in question.
Yes, this code.
This is what happens when you rewrite this function.
As you can see, the interest in how to iterate has been shortened as the following line.
It's in yellow.
And the most important interest of sum function,
that is, "How to keep adding" is the main interest of this code.
Isn't it much clearer?
This is the first example.
And now the next one.
This time, let's abstract the code that checked the value with a number of cases.
This code is boilerplate code for signInWithoAuth function
and typeOfNumber function that were in the previous example.
The variable elements of this code are the values
to be inspected and the number of cases to be inspected.
Just like the loop function I just showed,
we just need to parameterize these two elements, to get abstraction complete.
But this time, we're going to discuss parameterizing variable elements
in a different approach.
Firstly, the number of cases are variable, so are the number of each case.
For example, a computer has only two states, that are on and off,
but there are 9 different grades of school.
As such, the numbers of such cases must be expressed through the parameters.
Secondly, I would model the number of each case more simply.
In this boilerplate code, the number of cases were modeled as objects,
to express the identification as a test method, and the calculation to operate to operation method,
but for the simpler code, let me express the number of cases as a tuple instead of an object,
and place the test method as the first element, and the operation method as the second element.
Lastly, the first two aren't important due to the UX problem,
but the final problem is what I want to tell you the most, in the second example.
Lastly, we should separate the time when we receive a value to investigate, from when we receive the number of cases.
As we've seen earlier,
the places where codes are used to investigate the value with the number of cases
are mostly the places where you only know how the numbers are divided, not what values actually came in.
Therefore, we will split the operation in half, and receive the number of cases first,and then, receive the value to investigate.
Now, let's look at the code.
이제 코드를 한 번 보도록 하겠습니다.
This is the code.
바로 이 코드인데요.
Isn't it so simple?
간단하지 않나요?
We receive multiple cases as variable variables,
여기 가변 변수로 여러가지 경우의 수를 받고
and as going into loop when the price comes in,
check the number of cases,
and if a function that occupies the position of the test method called that predicate,
returns true, it's a simple code that executes the operation.
Let's use this function to rewrite the previous typeOfNumber function.
It's written as follows.
It looks much clearer.
The number of cases and the operation of them are seen at a glance.
I just gave you some time to think about it.
Is there anyone here who has the same question as I do?
If you look closely at the new code, the calculations that produce constants look very similar.
Which is called?
Yes, boilerplate code!
The boilerplate code should be removed.
This code can be removed simply through the function that receives
the constant as shown above, and returns the constant,
that is, the function called constant.
Good.
It's much more satisfactory.
For the next, we're going to look at a slightly unusual higher-order function.
Firstly, suppose there are three values, A, B, and C.
And a function f that makes the value A the value B,
and a function g that makes the value B the value C.
If you describe these elements in code, it will be as follows.
Since value A is unknown, the variable x,
and the function f, because calculation is the only thing we need,
can simply be a function to add 1.
If so, B is x+1.
g, just like f, can be a function to simply add 2.
c can be x+1+2.
However, here, x+1+2 is the same as x+3, as you already know.
If so, we can learn that there is the function h to add 3,
between value A and C.
And in terms of the function h adds 3, as we saw in inducing the function h,
can also be represented as the function f and the function g.
If you apply the f to A first, and then apply the g again to B that's obtained previously,
you can get C from A, just like the h.
Based on this, assume a function pipe that represents different functions with 2 functions,
we can represent the function h as pipe(f, g).
That is, representing big functions through small functions.
This cool function is often used in combining or connecting functions
in functional programming.
When you actually implement this function, it's as follows.
Let me show you an example of the real case that used this function.
For example, by applying a function to each value in the array as shown below,
we can create function values
to get the value of every property of an object,
by combining Object.entries function through pipe function.
Let me briefly explain how these values function works.
Firstly, we can deliver the object to get the value.
The value functions are as follows.
It's like the pipe(Object.entries, map(snd)).
It's just like definition of the values.
And we're going to change the pipe function back to the actual code here.
If you reduce the pipe, it will become as follows.
You can imagine the actual codes in each variable of the body in the pipe function.
And let's implement Object.entries in our head here.
Then, the entry of the properties come out as follows, right?
And lastly, oh, not lastly yet,
Let's iterate the map with the original code.
Yes, the f is changed to the snd function, and the array is changed to the array.map (snd) code.
To this point, calculation can be operated by filling the map function with snd function.
Let me shorten this code again.
The function that receives the array, and applies the map to the array,
and since the array was given with that entry,
it can provide the code as follows.
And from now on, those who used JavaScript a lot will find it so familiar.
The snd function is now applied to each element in the array, it gets 2 and 23 as the values.
We got the values.
What do you think? Isn't it so beautifully simple?
It was the pipe function that connects different functions, that is,
it helps to easily reuse small functions by combining them.
The function that we're going discuss now looks very insignificant.
It's a function that simply returns the given value.
But this function, surprisingly, is considered one of the greatest and most important functions,
along with the pipe mentioned earlier, in functional programming.
It may be hard to believe, but it's a function of great value, both theoretically and practically.
In fact, just by discussing this function, I could spend my entire presentation time that's given.
But we don't enough have time for that, and it's very complicated,
so I'll just give you one practical example.
This identity function is the same as 0 in addition, and 1 in multiplication.
If any function is associated with this function, the result is always that function.
If you combine any function with this identity function, it's supposed to be the same function.
I'll show you that here.
Here's the pipe code that combines the two functions, the f and the identity.
This code replaces the pipe function with the actual code:
And here, when you replace this identity function with the actual code, it changes as follows.
Then the arrow function that goes from x to x that follows,
and then you will see this after focusing on the part to apply the value f(x) on that,
and shortening the code by removing unnecessary parts of this part.
And lastly, this code will be the f, back again.
The function that takes a value,
executes the f with the value, and produces the result is, in fact, no different than the f.
It was just a cover.
Why is this trivial feature so important?
It's because, thanks to this feature, the identity function can act like the default function.
As you've seen so far,
functional programming brings together small operations to form a large operation.
They can continue the operation with such as the pipe,
or they can fill in the remaining blanks with the higher order function.
But sometimes I don't really want to fill in the blanks of some higher-order functions.
Indeed, I sometimes want to leave some blanks as they are, in such a huge higher-order function.
In other words, in some ways, you might want to take some basic actions.
Especially when that part has nothing to do with our interests.
In this case, the identity function acts as a basic action.
What's so useful about it is that, when you abstract a function,
it lets you drill through the blanks while also making it easier
to build up the function without having to worry about not using it.
Let me show you a practical example.
The bimap function that I'm going to show you now is a function that maps a function
to each field by receiving two functions and the tuple,
and it abstracts the operation that applies a function to the tuple.
This function is a function that receives a function, and maps the function only to the first field of the tuple.
It's also called the mapFst function.
The two are very similar functions, both conceptually and formally.
If you remove the g and the g(y) code from the bimap, it becomes the mapFst function.
But it doesnt seem possible to use bimap
to create the mapFst function.
But with the identity function, you can do this very simply.
You can change it like this.
If you just give the body of the bimap function the f and the tuple to make the mapFst function,
there will still be blanks in the function, with the unfilled parameters left, which makes it a function with blanks on the body.
If you implement it, you'll be scolded by what's called Runtime Error.
But if you add a function called identity that builds up a function,
as the identity function fills the blanks,
you can create a whole mapFst function with the bimap function.
As being a basic function, when you build a function, or drill a hole in the function,
it reduces concerns like, "Oh, I don't think I'm going to use it again." That's why it is a very valuable function.
I'd like to discuss how to look at a function from a variety of perspectives rather than introducing a function.
Currying is
a method of expressing a multiple arguments function as a column of a singular arguments function.
To put it more simply, currying was created by splitting arguments, and is a way of expressing a function.
Let me give you a simple example.
These are the two multiple arguments functions.
If you curry this function, the two arguments split as follows.
You'll receive arguments multiple times.
The following are two main reasons for using currying.
Firstly, it allows you to see the function from multiple angles.
Secondly, it makes it easier to perform techniques to fill in blanks with parameters of a function called partial application.
However, the first one is what we should pay attention to.
The second one is not only in the extension of the first one, but also because the first one is so powerful,
in order to spend our remaining time as valuable as possible, we should definitely focus on the first one.
If you're curious about the second advantage, you can ask me later, or look it up yourself.
So let's skip it for now.
So here's the function map that applies a function to each element in the array, and returns the result.
This function is actually very familiar to who use modern JavaScript.
And now the function Array.prototype.map that you're familiar with is just the one did wrapping.
Since objects that execute methods can also be viewed as parameters,
the function that makes this explicit is this one.
If you change the order of the parameters of this function, and do currying on the function, the function called lift comes out, as shown as follows.
It's safe to say that the two functions are functionally matched.
And yet, the reason I've distinguished these two functions in name is because
the interpretation and meaning of the role of the functions varies.
Let me show you an example of the changed use of the lift function.
So here's the not function that negates the given value.
In short, it is the functional version of the not operator.
Apply the lift function to this function to create a function called liftedNot.
Like this.
What are the differences between these two functions?
Yeah, it's just that, while the not denies only one given value,
the liftedNot performs a negative operation on all elements of the given array.
In terms of type, it's as follows.
The not goes from boolean to boolean, and the liftedNot goes from array Boolean to array Boolean.
Now, do you see everything at a glance?
A function that worked on a simple value has become a function that works on an array.
Through the lift function.
It's that the lift function lifted the given function to the array function.
What do you think? We just split the arguments, and changed the order of the function, but its meaning has changed a lot, right?
Firstly, just applying the function to each element of an array, and to apply a function to an array that returns the result,
but after a slight conversion with currying,
it became a function to lift a function for a simple value, to one for an array,
that is, the higher level function.
This is the power of currying.
What lets us see the same function from a different point of view,
to give different meanings.
So far, we've been discussing the basic ideas of functional programming
that can help removing boilerplate code.
In addition to the pipe, the identity, and currying that I introduced earlier,
functional programmers have come up with
beautiful and really wise concepts through their consideration of functions.
Unfortunately, due to the limited time today, I can't introduce all of those concepts.
but those of you who are curious about it, I'd like to briefly introduce some of the deeper concepts.
Firstly, Y Combinator.
Y Combinator is a non-recursive function that makes a given function a recursive function.
It sounds really contradictory.
This function lets us think deeply about the nature of recursion,
that is, inductive thinking.
If you really want to understand recursions well,
I strongly recommend you to look it up.
The next one is functor.
Functor is the same as the lift function that was previously discussed in currying.
The technique of lifting a given general function to a function for a data structure is called lifting.
The concept of abstracting these lifting types is called functor.
Those of you who think it's cool to introduce with a function,
might want to look up for functor.
The next one is monad.
Monad is a concept that abstracts operations that can be combined.
It's actually a concept that's too hard for me to explain simply.
But I'd like to introduce you to this concept because once you've studied it,
you will have a really deep insight into how to deal with operations
including what is an operation, how to handle it, and how to define it.
And also, this is the technology that works the most,
in functional programming, to remove boilerplate code.
Now, if you want to study more about removing boilerplate code using functional programming,
I recommend you to look up this concept.
The final concept is called optics.
Optics is a concept about the relationship between an arbitrary structure and the part that can be derived from it.
The fields and accessors of objects can also be explained through this concept.
I'm not sure if anyone has heard of lens.
The concept of lens is also a part of optics.
So now, if you want to get both insight for structured data and for calculation,
I strongly recommend you to take look up for this concept.
I've attached good materials to the slides.
So, i you want to study this concept,
I recommend you to download the slides when they are released.
And I didn't write it down because it had nothing to do with boilerplate code,
but it's a good topic to learn about.
There are basic concepts of functional programming, such as 'pure function' and 'partial application'.
If you're curious about functional programming, you can take a look at them.
So, that's all for today.
From now on, we will wrap up the presentation by looking at what we discussed today.
First of all, we discussed boilerplate code.
Boilerplate code is repetitive.
And it had some problems,
which is, causing unnecessary cognitive loads.
And we've discussed a number of ways, including object-oriented programming.
But there were limitations, and we discussed functional programming with a new approach to solve those limitations.
I introduced you to the idea of the higher-order functions in functional programming.
Also, the pipe function that connects functions, and the special function called identity.
Lastly, I introduced currying, a way to see functions from different point of views.
That's all I discussed today.
Lastly, I'd like to conclude as follows.
In this presentation, we briefly looked at how we could access boilerplate code through functional programming.
An approach based on the idea of splitting an operation into smaller pieces as a function for functional programming
can be complementary to an idea of dividing the program of the object-oriented programming into objects.
There are two main ways to solve the quadratic equation.
One is to factorize the quadratic formula, and the other is to use the quadratic formula.
Do you have any idea which is better?
Of course, the answer is 'unanswerable'.
The method of dispensing a quadratic equation is
very effective when the given equation is really easily subdivided and easily subdivided through the formula.
Just by a few operations to divide by integers, it can quickly determine the two values, that are, the roots.
However, if the given formula is not easily subdivided, or if the two roots are imaginary ones, it won't be so efficient.
Since you have to deal with numbers in a wider range than the integer, even a few calculations will be very complicated.
The quadratic formula, on the other hand,
is much easier to solve because you just need to put numbers in a fixed frame.
But since the fixed frame is basically not small in size,
it will be a little inconvenient to use this method, even when it can be easily solved by the factorization.
The same goes for the functional programming and the object-oriented programming.
Both can be used to fix boilerplate code.
Both the functional programming and the object-oriented programming prevail, depending on situations.
There is a saying, 'A good craftsman never blames their tools.'
It can be interpreted as 'A talented person can work with any tools,'
but it can be interpreted a little differently.
Like this.
'A talented person only uses tools that fit the situation.'
As programmers who solves problems, rather than sticking to only one method,
we should learn all the tools , and use them in the right place.
So I'd like to say one last thing to you.
Let's all be craftsmen.
Thank you so much for following me through this long session.